there's a really important distinction
between being objective and being
neutral neutral is sort of a proactive
decision that you are going to kind of
play both sides and concoct or fabricate
a position where it doesn't appear as
though you are taking aside as you're
pointing out just about everybody has
some kind of bias even if it's not a
political bias there can be advertiser
bias or corporate bias or whatever kind
of bias objectivity I find to be much
more interesting and more important and
that's what I try to do so when I make
an assessment of what I think is a good
policy or not a good policy I'm not
pretending to have a position that is
any different from my true you know
sincere genuine position but I try to be
objective in accurately characterizing
what my opposition's views are why they
came to those conclusions so on and so
forth so I think a lot of times
neutrality is the wrong goal and
objectivity is sort of a better thing to
strive for
alright well let's have you give us a
little bit of a breakdown of your
background before your show sure so I
was born in Argentina my family moved to
the US when I was a little kid learned
English went to school in the US and
ended up at the University of
Massachusetts where I started a
community radio hour at a very small
basement community radio station and
from there it became a podcast a
syndicated radio show put cameras in the
studio
after meeting Genk from the young turks
who in 2008 said I think there might be
a future on YouTube so you might want to
start filming what you're doing so I did
that and then we partnered up with free
speech TV which is on DirecTV and Dish
and that's kind of been the show since
and then you know we've grown over time
added staff and ad sales and it sort of
changed over those years but that was
like the genesis of it when I was at the
University of Massachusetts and was
interested in politics wanted to do
something in media and the opportunity
sort of presented itself so you were
what like 21 when you saw I was 21
that's right what made you want to start
it in the first place boredom mostly I
mean I was looking for something
additional to do other than just being
in college and having some kind of
part-time job so it was once every other
week it could have become nothing I
could have just kind of left it when I
finished my bachelor's degree but I
liked it enough that I thought let me
see if I can keep doing this while I'm
in grad school getting my MBA saw my MBA
classmates become management consultants
and audit people that type of thing
which was not appealing to me at all so
at that point I said I'm gonna give it a
year of just focusing on this like it is
my job and we were sort of a combination
of timing and other things that fell
into place where it became a full-time
job and now we employ a number of people
and we have investors in the show and
it's it's a real thing it's amazing how
it all happened slowly but we've come a
really long way from you know when I was
at UMass as a junior right and has it
always been politically based basically
yeah it's mostly u.s. politics
some international some current events
the interviews are pretty wide-ranging
so I'll interview politicians but also
people from the music industry or
professors authors fiction authors
sometimes it's really whatever I am
interested in but it's mostly politics
gotcha and is it true that for a while
you were the youngest nationally
syndicated political host I read that
for a while but I'm much older but
you're not yeah I don't you know it's
funny because now I don't even really
follow radio anymore even though it's
still a part of what I do because it's
become so secondary both in terms of my
audience and the sort of revenue sources
that we're dealing with and it's
incredible because when I had started
the show I never would have even dreamed
of being on as many radio stations as we
are now and now that I am on all those
radio stations it's really become very
secondary or even tertiary to the
business model because so much of the
audience has moved online yeah it's so
we've had on a few guests that come from
companies that started off as radio
shows and they were radio successful
radio shows for decades and then they
were smart enough their company to
realize that they needed to make this
shift to like like digital YouTube
podcasts and I think they're very much
in the same boat where it's like yeah we
have these nationally syndicated shows
it's great we're all over the place but
like the focus has very very much
changed so I think it's very interesting
yeah and we I mean I I would never think
of not having the show on radio or
television anymore but it definitely has
changed how I think about the content
we're thinking about it as having to be
structured in a way that fits on radio
it's still something we do but it's not
nearly as important as it was at the
very beginning when how where can the
brakes fit in from our local affiliates
in all of those questions they're really
not questions anymore we just kind of do
it if they're interested in it great but
the focus has become the online audience
yeah and for people who might not know
your political leaning and your show
comes from a progressive perspective
right that's right yeah it's a left-wing
show it's an opinion show there's no
hiding that there's no you know
pretending that this is on the one hand
the other hand thing but actually being
a progressive show those are my politics
and it's always been a show that's that
that's what it's about really with the
exception of like at the very beginning
there was a very short period of time
where I was sort of scared to just give
my opinion yeah because I was correctly
assessing that I would start getting a
lot of hate and angry ads and whatnot
but then I realized number one it's
really boring for me to do on the one
hand on the other hand type of thing and
I was getting the hate anyway because a
lot of people don't like centrism anyway
so there was like no opposite in doing
that and after like two months I said
I'm just gonna do every story the way I
see it for better or worse and if people
don't like it as long as they aren't
liking it with the correct understanding
of what my views are then that I can
deal with it and that's fine
yeah well I mean so so yeah I think
you're absolutely right and that
nobody's gonna be happy no matter what
you do so if you wanted to do that you
may as well but also like we kind of
laugh around here about some programs
and look if they truly feel that way and
they can do it good for them but there's
a lot of there's a lot of programs out
there that try so hard to tell it that
they are are neutral or that they're
both sides and it's so hard to do that
unless that is your number one goal
there's actually one guy I don't know if
you've ever heard of him it's uh it's
called like agenda free TV or something
like that have you heard of them no I am
it's like I think it's new I thought I
don't think he's been doing it long he
said he actually does a pretty good job
of like it's like pretty boring he'll
just like sit when breaking news is
happening and see what's going on but
but for the most part I feel like most
people have their slants I'm biases
I mean I think that there's a really
important distinction between being
objective and being neutral neutral is
sort of a proactive decision that you
are going to kind of play both sides and
concoct or fabricate a position where it
doesn't appear as though you are taking
aside as you're pointing out just about
everybody has some kind of bias even if
it's not a political bias there can be
advertiser bias or corporate bias or
whatever kind of bias objectivity I find
to be much more interesting and more
important and that's what I try to do so
when I make an assessment of what I
think is a good policy or not a good
policy I'm not pretending to have
position that is any different from my
true you know sincere genuine position
but I try to be objective in accurately
characterizing what my opposition's
views are why they came to those
conclusions so on and so forth so I
think a lot of times neutrality is the
wrong goal and objectivity is sort of a
better thing to strive for oh that's
interesting and and while we're talking
about you know interviewing people and
kind of being in the space I mean so
you've been involved in the political
sphere for what 15 years however many
years have you over that time have you
seen a rise in the intensity and the way
that we talk about like political issues
or politicians or has it always been
this contentious I think it's always
been this contentious in terms of the
strength of people's disagreements but I
think particularly in the last couple of
years there's been sort of a core
sinning of the discourse that's
acceptable and I think that certainly
the president has been encouraging that
we've had a president who talks in a way
that we've not seen any president it's
certainly in the modern era of
audio-visual records of how a president
behaves so I think there's definitely
been a sort of corseting in terms of
what counts as valid political debate
and discourse I don't actually believe
that the disagreements are any more
significant the disagreements have been
pretty significant in the political
world for a long time but the way we
talk about them I think has definitely
changed mm-hmm I mean this is you're
living like this is what you talk about
every day does it does the
contentiousness ever get to you it does
I mean I go out of my way to stay almost
completely off of social media on
weekends and after hours I don't pay
attention to the news on weekends I'll
go visit my mom and she'll say did you
see what and I'll say you know I didn't
and it's I'm not working right now and
just really having calculated and
planned time off from it because it gets
very very toxic for sure yeah yeah I
mean we were just yesterday we had a
shoot with another guest and it hasn't
aired yet so I won't say who but we were
talking about how the role of social
and 24-hour news cycles might be
contributing to this this divisive nasai
I don't know if you feel the same way
but it was a really interesting
conversation not on how it's just like
we have a we have a hard time with it
he's also like like pretty involved in
in the space and he had an incident it
was he had like a live event and there
was a huge strong reaction to it that he
got a lot of blowback online he was like
I I I'm like not on Twitter anymore
because of it yeah I know a lot of
people who have opted out of some of
those social media platforms you know I
still use them all because they are
important my brand and for spreading
awareness about what I'm doing and
growing an audience but I recently
interviewed Cal Newport after reading a
number of his books including deep work
and digital minimalism and it's just
abundantly clear that there's something
very negative about the sort of constant
scrolling social media culture it's
proactively making people less satisfied
with their lives it's increasing anxiety
and depression and so I'm trying to find
a balance between what's good for me as
an individual while at the same time you
know having a role and a presence on all
of these platforms because one of the
reasons why it's so important now to
focus on the online platforms and less
on radio and television for me is
because social media has allowed those
online platforms to become so big so I
can't neglect them but at the same time
it's all about sort of finding a balance
and finding the right amount of exposure
to that to those platforms right it's
like such an irony every time I go on
Twitter and like say something bad about
Twitter it's like but I also I'm on it
because I I get it I understand it yeah
so I mean in in relation to all this you
know I feel like with everything
becoming so divided right now it's
becoming really taboo to talk with
people I mean kind of generally but
especially people we don't agree with
but I know that over the years you've
interviewed people that you don't agree
with I know like Richard Spencer a white
supremacist why do you think it's
important to to talk with people you
don't agree with even those who are
considered controversial well I think
it's important depending on
how you do it right so I'm basically my
philosophy is that of responsible
platforming which is any decision I make
about a guest is sort of an evaluation
of a few different things number one how
prominent are they or their ideas number
two is it worth refuting ideas that are
bad or is it better to sort of let them
leave them alone and let them
potentially die out and number three am
I going to be like well enough equipped
and prepared to be the person refuting
those bad ideas and if the answer to any
of those questions comes to the point
where I don't think that there's
actually an advantage for my worldview
and my philosophy to interview someone
then I won't so my main concern when I
interview someone like Richard Spencer
or whoever else is I want to be really
well-prepared for when I hear something
that I don't agree with when I hear
something that I think is damaging for
our society the idea of separating
people by race
the idea of getting people out on the
basis of a religious belief or ethnicity
or whatever I want to make sure that I'm
prepared to take those ideas take them
on head-on in a way that I feel good
about because the last thing I would
want to even be flirting with or dancing
with doing is giving someone a platform
merely to espouse bad ideas in a way
that could actually grow support for
those ideas or it could be it could
accomplish the exact opposite of what
I'm looking to do so so you you only
want to have them just so I can be clear
because I think this is the sounds were
kind of similar to what Oprah did back
in the day when she had the KKK on you
don't want to just give them a play if
it's someone that you think like how
should a dangerous idea you don't want
to just give them a platform to just
share their idea you want to I don't
want to use the word challenge if that's
not what you mean but kind of I do want
a challenge and you know I don't want it
so in my head I'm thinking let's say
it's twenty years from now and either
the ideas of this guest have grown and
have become mainstreamed which would be
horrible or they've died away and people
twenty years from now
may have significantly moved on from
these ideas as sort of being dangerous
if I do an interview where I give
someone a platform to talk about race
their racist views or homophobic views
or whatever it is that I find
objectionable in whatever way what well
I sort of have accomplished by leaving
that interview as part of the historical
record right the fact that these ideas
existed that's a pretty low bar for me
and I think most people in the West who
have access to media know that these bad
ideas exist so I feel much better about
the idea that if in 20 years someone
looks back on my interview with Richard
Spencer no matter what's happened with
the alt-right and with white nationalism
it will be clear that I challenge the
ideas and that I believed that they were
bad and that's something I can actually
feel good about rather than saying talk
about white supremacy or whatever else
it might be do you get a lot of blowback
when you do talk to to these
controversial figures or do do you get a
good amount of acceptance actually it's
a mix from both the left and the right
there's people on the right that like
the idea of me talking to some of these
extreme right-wing figures because they
like their ideas that's a very different
motivation than mine there's people on
the Left who appreciate my attempts to
expose these ideas and push back against
them and there are people on both sides
including on the Left which is which is
sort of the side that I'm on who say
it's not good to platform these ideas
we're better off just ignoring them all
together and I just disagree with that
as a general principle I think you
really got to analyze it case by case a
good example is the Westboro Baptist
Church that's known for their God hates
[ __ ] slogan very little media coverage
you you really hear very little about
them right now so I've stopped
interviewing them I don't think that
their views are noteworthy in any way
nor are they worth challenging anymore
ten years ago when they were regularly
in the news for protesting the funerals
of soldiers who had died and doing all
sorts of other horrible things they were
getting enough media attention that was
not directly challenging them gay
marriage was not legal at the time etc
where I made the calculation that this
is worth refuting that's changed so they
no longer appear on my program so it's
sort of something that evolves and you
really
have to take it on a case-by-case basis
how do you think that works for for the
state of discourse today because I think
a lot of people agree with that approach
but I think also a lot of people are
lowering their standards for what they
consider to be acceptable topics to
discuss for example like I wouldn't be
surprised if let's say some people on
the right would say talking to you might
be too far mm-hmm
I've never heard that before oh I pull
that out of nowhere
so when you say lowering standards do
you mean making them more relaxed or
tighter or I mean what they consider to
be dangerous ideas that shouldn't be
shared I feel like the bar for that is
starting to get a little bit lower I'm
trying to think of an example like maybe
having on a guest to talk about why they
like let's say like a like pro-life okay
like meet some people would probably say
that we shouldn't even have someone on
it like someone who's you know
pro-choice that we shouldn't even have
someone on to talk about the case for
pro-life the pro-life case someone who's
pro-life would say that there shouldn't
be someone who's pro-choice on I think I
might not have understood this yeah or I
guess talking with people who don't
agree with our sides if that makes sense
yeah I mean listen there will be always
be people who want to suppress the
speech of those that they disagree with
for different reasons it could be
because they view the Opposition as
posing such a significant challenge that
rather than engage they want to just
shut down the debate and sometimes that
can be a sign of the weakness of their
argument in other words if you are on
the side of so-called climate skepticism
I call it class yes yeah you might want
to do everything you can to silence the
pro-science voices what we call the
consensus what we call the reality based
approach because you see that as a
serious challenge to your climate denial
views in other words you believe that in
a fair sort of confrontation and a
battle of ideas so to speak to use a
cliche term you believe that the prosign
side is going to come out
on top so rather than engage with them
you might try to prevent them from even
having a voice that would be sort of one
reason why someone might try to do that
there's all sorts of other reasons why
someone might try to do that that's not
my view so my view tends to be let's
engage in these questions and discuss
these issues up to the point at which
earlier we talked about objectivity
versus neutrality at a certain point
reality has to influence sort of how the
discourse is happening I don't know
where the line is but as an example with
climate change when 99.98% of
peer-reviewed science has a very strong
consensus on what is going on with the
climate does it make sense for corporate
media to have 50/50 balance between the
science side and the science denying
side when the consensus is ninety-nine
point eight I don't know so I think that
there are real questions about that but
that's more about decisions that are
being made at the individual media
outlet level then sort of broader issues
of suppressing and silencing voices
which maybe is more what what you wanted
to to talk about there which I'm glad to
sure yeah I just what are your general
thoughts on that my view is well on my
program I sort of have laid it out which
is if the idea is prominent enough to
either talk about or attempt to refute
and I think that I'm a good person to do
that
then I'll do the interview I get pitched
stuff all the time that I turned down
because it's not interesting to me and
ultimately the program is what what is
interesting to me I don't think the
ideas are prominent enough they're very
obscure you know conspiracy theories for
example that I don't think are worth
refuting but my view is one where I want
more speech as long as it's responsibly
platformed responsibly platform that's
interesting way to put it yeah well
that's what I that's that would I
outlined before yeah yeah how prominent
are these are the ideas are they worth
refuting and am i well-equipped to do it
myself yeah I think that's interesting
cuz a lot of platforms
I think they don't look at it that way
so I think that's kind of cool
responsibly platform yeah gotcha
well let's switch gears because while I
have you I want to pick your brain about
an area that that you're knowledgeable
about that Utah
a lot about sure I want to ask you about
your perspective on socialism okay
I know you had previously mentioned that
you feel like a lately a lot of the
critique on the political left like
towards the political left is oftentimes
a critique on socialism and that you
don't think that that's really a fair
critique well critiquing socialism is
perfectly fair the question is is there
a significant socialist movement in the
Democratic Party in the United States
the reality is we have two strong
parties the Republican Party the
Democratic Party so are the ideas
espoused by the Democratic Party and its
members in the House and Senate and
recent Democratic presidents are those
socialist ideas or not because if
they're not the critique of socialism
becomes sort of a straw man it's a
critique of something that is not really
present or prevalent and my argument is
that there is almost no socialism
whatsoever in the Democratic Party I'm
willing to entertain any particular
socialist idea that has come from the
Democratic Party or discuss whether any
particular individual politician is a
socialist but I'm not aware of that and
I think that the misunderstanding about
what is socialism what is communism what
a social democracy which is really you
know the furthest left that the
Democratic Party gets in terms of
elected officials in the House and
Senate is basically social democracy in
the line of Denmark Finland etc if we
can't even sort of understand what are
the ideas it's really hard to have a
serious discussion about whether
something is or isn't a good idea and
that socialism attack is inaccurate and
it's a very big distraction from really
talking about how should health care be
organized
how should education be organized how
should taxation work and there's very
little actual socialism to even argue
against but it's a it's a good technique
for the right to call things of
socialism because it does still trigger
a visceral reaction in many people well
let's talk about the definitions then
cuz I actually would agree with you that
I think probably most of us aren't
entirely clear on the differences
between social democracy democratic
socialism
you know probably even a lot of people
with like communism fascism capitalism
sure um so do you mind a like like
breaking down social democracy versus
democratic socialism sure so in the
simplest simplest terms and this is
fabulous you know in invariably there
will be people who disagree with my
assessment but I think that this is at
least a good initial framework social
democracy is capitalism it's a mixed
economy it's an economy that is
capitalist there's private ownership of
businesses there's the ability to become
very wealthy if you have a successful
business all of those things it's a
capitalist system that decides to
prioritize use of government revenue
taxes etc to make sure that people don't
get left behind to sort of raise the
very very bottom typically by imposing
growing taxes at the very top that's
social democracy generally speaking so
Denmark would be an example Sweden is an
example Finland is an example Norway is
another example and these are capitalist
countries there's private ownership of
business there's lots of very rich
people some of those countries in fact
are ranked as having better business
environments and business climates than
the United States but it's the
prioritizing of the money that the
government takes in for particular
purposes often it's health care
regardless of ability to pay
sometimes it's maternity and paternity
leave whatever socialism is speaking
very generally most of the time when we
want to simply define socialism we're
talking about socializing ownership of
businesses meaning that businesses
instead of being privately owned like
instead of me owning my show and the ad
agency that we run it would be owned by
all of the employees it would socialize
that ownership rather than concentrating
it among the CEO the founder whoever it
is and then they they decide what to do
with them that's right exactly everybody
together would sort of have shared
responsibility over that business and
communism would be when the state takes
ownership of the businesses now there
are gray areas there is there are
different types of communism and
socialism
but generally speaking that's what we're
talking about and with that very basic
definition it becomes very clear that
there's very or almost no clamoring or
serious possibility of for example a
socialist president being elected in
2020 I mean none of the candidates that
are running have almost any socialist
ideas as an example so when we hear of
the rise of a pro socialist
position in the US you're saying that
that's generally speaking about social
I'm getting the to mix up social
democracy there's two things going on in
the so-called rise of socialism one is
that there is a less negative view of
socialism currently then there has been
in the u.s. in a long time
now part of that is because the sort of
vulture capitalism as we call it has
gone awry in many many ways we can see
that in terms of the level of income
inequality that exists in the United
States we can see it in so many other
ways medical bankruptcies etc etc so
part of it is even if one doesn't
identify as a socialist themselves
certainly when capitalism is so boldly
imploding in our faces
you are going to logically it seems to
me have maybe a less negative view or be
more open to socialism the other part of
that though is again this confusion
between socialism and social democracy
and on the actual issues if you ask
people how should health care be
organized how should taxation be
organized etc most people are talking
about social democracy which is slightly
higher taxes on the very wealthy
restructuring the relationship between
individuals and healthcare to not run
mostly through employers but to run in a
different way so it is a lot of
confusion about the terms as well mm-hmm
and and so I mean social democracy and I
think just the the idea of wealth
distribution in any sense gets a lot of
blowback from people who don't agree
with it obviously what are some of the
critiques on on that so I mean I know
some that I've heard but I'm sure you
probably you might even know quite
specifically about the idea of
just distributing wealth instead of
having a you know a total free market
where everyone has their own money and
they get to keep it and do with it what
they want and and the argument that that
can help people like freedom can help
people flourish more than a higher
taxation and centralized programs ban
well so let's see where to start I know
there's a lot of stuff in there that is
sort of in conflict with itself so let's
see if we can break it down into a few
pieces one thing is it's important to
understand that the government and our
society already is making decisions
about how wealth should be distributed
or redistributed so when we decide as a
society to tax capital gains meaning
gains on ownership stakes in businesses
or stocks for example at a much lower
rate for very rich people than wages
that is a way in which we are
redistributing wealth from the middle
class to the very rich who
disproportionately are owning those
shares of stock so it's really important
not to fall for the idea that the
baseline is not redistributing wealth
but that taxing the rich slightly more
would be imposing a redistribution we're
what we already have significant
redistribution I'll give you another
example when we lower the tax rate on
corporations from I believe it was
thirty five percent up until 2017 under
the Trump Republican tax reform plan the
business corporate tax rate went down
went down to 21 percent the country as a
whole still needs the same amount of
money and more to fund what we're doing
which is why the the deficit continues
to grow so when you get less of that
money from corporations it's coming from
somewhere else someone else is going to
have to pay for that that's already a
redistribution so it's really important
not to think about this issue as is it
fair to go from no redistribution to
redistribution because that's not the
status quo what we want to be thinking
about is what redistributions are
happening right now what are we saying
we allow companies for example like
Amazon to pay no taxes and someone else
is paying for that compared to well
maybe let's make them pay their fair
share maybe let's make the very very
rich pay their fair share it's already
being redistributed the question is how
do we want to do it that's really
important to understand and and so what
about the argument that the more money
that corporations say like Amazon keep
then the more that they can the more
jobs they can offer them more yeah yeah
the higher maybe they can raise their
wages sure things like that these are
all very old and very tired arguments
from what's called supply-side economics
mostly some people call it Reaganomics
some people call it voodoo economics
it's basically bogus and we can take
each of each piece one at a time if you
want when we look for example at the
2017 Trump tax reform business has got a
tax cut like we just said thirty five
percent down to twenty one percent it
was sold to us as businesses are gonna
go crazy investing in themselves
everybody's gonna make more money wages
are going to go up it's gonna be just so
great it'll all pay for itself obviously
it hasn't paid for itself deficit as
record-high but what businesses did with
the money was disproportionately just go
and repurchase shares of their own stock
who is that good for well it raises the
price of the stock so the people who
owned most of the stock are the ones
that benefit that is disproportionately
very rich people hedge funds etc and
executives at those corporations so the
idea that if as a business you get a tax
cut you're gonna go hire more people
makes no sense because business is
higher based on demand primarily and
they have much more immediately positive
ways to self enrich that they would use
those tax cuts my business is an example
I mean as a result of the Trump tax
reform plan my business is an S
corporation which means that the income
is packed it passes through to the
shareholders I'm one of those
shareholders even though my business
grew from twenty seventeen to twenty
eighteen pretty significantly my
effective tax rate went from twenty six
percent to twenty two percent so the
question is not do I like keeping more
of
money sure right I mean in the vacuum I
give I'd love to keep a hundred percent
of my money the question is economically
societally what makes sense and what
what should be done with that I don't go
and hire more people because my
effective tax rate went down I would
hire more people if there's demand for
the product and service that I'm
offering that justifies hiring more
people if you're Amazon and you get a
huge tax break or a huge tax refund that
doesn't make more people want your stuff
that's why you would go and hire more
people so that's one example and if
there's others you want to go through we
can go through them I guess those are
all like supply-side arguments that are
very widely debunked or but on that
argument of but maybe not hiring people
but would you consider expanding your
business and anyway maybe better
equipment or a bigger studio or anything
like that here's what's fascinating
about that a higher tax rate would
incentivize me to do that more than a
lower tax rate why is that I'm I'm gonna
try to explain this as simply as
possible if the tax rate is 30% so I get
let's back up even a second it's really
important to understand that business
expenses are tax deductible so if your
business makes $100,000 and spends
$50,000 on wages and equipment whatever
you're paying taxes on the $50,000
that's left over so when you spend money
you avoid taxes if I spend another
hundred bucks as a business owner that's
a hundred bucks I'm not going to pay
taxes on what makes more sense as an
incentive for me to spend money to avoid
a 30% tax or for me to spend money to
avoid a 20% tax
well I'm incentivized to avoid a higher
tax rate so very interestingly this is
one of the most widely circulated bogus
talking points about supply-side
economics the incentive to invest in
your own business to avoid taxes is
higher when the tax rate is higher now
there's a limit to this because I know
that there will be supply siders who
will say David hold on that doesn't work
for like a 95 percent tax rate you would
just stop working that's correct all of
these things exist within a normal
spectrum right so nobody's talking about
an
ninety-five percent tax rate on
businesses but you are more incentivized
to avoid a higher rate of tax by
investing in your business so then would
okay so that's interesting all right
your reaction the look on your face is
really important because this is I have
this conversation all the time with
people and I see the wheels turning and
people go that's right that I would
rather avoid a 30% tax than a 20% tax
the 20% tax might make me say I'll just
pay the 20% in poll right and and and
I'm I'm I'm I'm not really pushing back
I'm really just trying to cuz you're the
first person we've had on to really dig
deep into the social democracy Fortin to
talk about this because so many of these
things a talking point gets circulated
and it gets repeated sometimes for 30
years four years and only when you
really start thinking about it can you
start to kind of pull it apart and have
these conversations and what's really
important is I have this conversation
with people who very strongly push back
against what I'm saying but I have that
conversation in a way that is respectful
it's polite I'm genuinely seeking to
find the truth about this stuff and if
someone came to me and said now here's
what you're forgetting David when you
make that explanation I would say that
that's really interesting I'm gonna go
research that because I actually want to
understand the truth of these issues and
I think that there's a lot to be gained
by really trying to pull them apart in
this way gotcha so so okay so we've had
on quite a few of very pro free-market
people and I think that they have a
general issue with the idea of like
again I don't wanna use the word social
isn't social democracy how would you
like to hide you cuz I don't know what
they have an issue with because I didn't
see the interview but I'm curious we're
like say like those who call it like
theft right okay like what do you think
about that general argument that why
should my money be taken and used in
ways that I don't necessarily want it to
be used for well so wow I mean so let's
see there are low tax conservatives who
want the lowest necessary tax there are
people who go beyond that and they are
more sort of extreme libertarians who
sometimes take the argument that
taxation of any kind of theft or even
slavery sometimes they will use that
word I find it I mean they're pretty out
there so I don't find myself super
inclined to debunk that notion super
specifically because I've done it a
bunch of times and if you're so far out
that you think to any tech level of
Taxation is theft you're probably not
going to see reason but I think there's
a few important things sort of to keep
in mind about that number one is if you
don't like the level of Taxation in the
United States or how those taxes are
being used there's lots of things you
can do right you're not a slave so to
speak if another country will have you
right I mean every countries have
immigration policies you could move to a
country whose tax policy is more in line
with what you like you could choose not
to work you're not being forced to work
I mean yeah you'll have to figure out
some way to survive but again you're not
being forced to work and pay taxes if
you pay taxes the government is going to
collect the tax
you are interestingly enough I mean you
I think the onus on someone who says
that taxes are theft the onus would be
on them to explain how can groups of
humans beyond several hundred be
organized without some kind of central
government and a lot of really
interesting anthropological work
including the work of for example like
Jared Diamond has made it abundantly
clear that if humans want to organize to
do anything in groups that are much
larger than a few hundred it's
effectively impossible without some kind
of organizing central government and
that's where a lot of these libertarian
ideas sort of get stopped up because
they will often say well there will sort
of be some kind of free-market system
that will decide who's in charge and it
will end up just being the guys with
guns which is one of the criticisms they
often have of the government that
ultimately it's guys with guns that are
enforcing stuff well at least we've sort
of elected them right I mean we might
not love the way our electoral system
works but it is a system so I find it
very difficult to really go through that
logic with extreme libertarians because
they're typically unwilling to even
enter
a lot of a lot of these ideas but if the
argument is a more sort of centrist one
of I don't like exactly how taxes are
being used that's something we can deal
with let's elect people right we have a
choice in who we elect let's elect
people that will do what we want them to
do with our tax money there's other
sorts of recourse but you know the other
thing is more lazy fair countries more
free-market countries so to speak and
countries that are more socially
democratic they all have taxes and they
all allocate them within a relatively
sort of narrow range it's relatively
small differences that exist when you
get to the end of it and if someone just
disagrees with taxes as a concept period
I don't know that there's anywhere left
on the planet that they can really go
and have that be the kind of prevailing
status quo and what about those who make
the argument that having centrally
controlled programs education healthcare
hurts the quality of these programs I
guess I'd have to know more about
exactly how they're measuring that and
sort of what they're asserting I think
certainly with healthcare we have
endless examples you know there's about
a dozen different systems in countries
ranging from Canada to the UK France
Germany not all of these systems are the
same but they all work better than the
system in the United States and costly I
think that the healthcare argument is
such a hard one for me because I feel
like I am constantly hearing conflicting
information on that I'm hearing that in
Canada in the Nordic countries that it's
great you know it's obviously free and
it's better and it's universal but then
I also hear that that's actually not the
case and that life expectancy in cancer
survival rates are better in America
like I'm just constantly hearing
conflicting information all that well
there's a very well-funded effort to
make it really muddy in the United
States in order to prevent people from
realizing that almost any system would
be better than the system we have now
you mentioned a few different arguments
got to really unpack them one by one
yeah it's and because the systems are so
different in each country there's no
single criticism that is going to apply
to all of the countries that are out
there that have different systems so
Canada for example has a province based
system of care that is administered by
each province so they're all they're
different well it's there they they're
administered at the provincial level
they're very similar programs but
they're administered in that way and the
relationship between the care providers
and the provincial government is one
sort of relationship in other countries
you actually have governments that run
the health facilities or that are
administering the health facilities
which are still privately run but the
health insurance piece for example might
be funded through taxation so in order
to really think about this we have to
have more narrow critique so like even
when we say cancer survival rates are
better in the u.s. than in other
countries for example we've got to talk
about which country and what type of
cancer because there is no one answer to
that often times cancer survival rates
can depend on how sick are the patients
at the point of diagnosis how much early
screening is there just because a
survival rate is higher doesn't
necessarily mean that it's because the
healthcare system is better it can be
that for whatever reason people are
having a less severe form of that cancer
for example so as you can see it's super
complicated and nuanced and there's no
sort of net that we can throw and say
here's 10 issues that I've heard and
let's kind of discuss it we've really
got to break them down one by one do you
think the fact that America is so
diverse and so populated changes our
conversation with specifically health
care actually probably even education to
a lot of these issues the fact that
we're so diverse do you think that that
like changes anything for us that that
maybe other countries don't have to
think about as much in what way would
diversity affect it um well don't um
you know when it comes to health like
genes genealogy when it comes to
education you know you know I was having
probably like mmm probably so many more
pockets of different subcultures
different states cities within those
states well let's think about health
care first so genetics mmm the idea I
want to make sure I understand the idea
the idea is that healthcare in the u.s.
is different than in some other
countries in some way because of genetic
diversity in the United States
oh I'm just posing the question I
honestly I honestly have no idea of I
don't know yeah I can't think of a way
and which difference yeah yeah I don't
I'm not aware of any way in which that
would make a difference I mean certainly
having a larger population lets you
spread the risk over more people and the
more the larger your risk pool when it
comes to uneven outcomes I mean that's
that's the thing about health care which
is that different people will have
different health care needs throughout
their life a lot of people will have
relatively small health care needs until
very very late in life other people will
have acute health care needs at
individual points due to injury for
example or certain conditions and then
some people will have sort of very
expensive chronic care for chronic
conditions and the more people you have
across whom you can spread that risk the
better you can sort of anticipate what
your total healthcare need will be so
that's one way in which having a bigger
population would be good for
transitioning to some kind of universe
or a single-payer system and can you
talk about like the the state of
Obamacare and I'm asking from someone
who genuinely genuinely knows very very
little about it the successes and the
failures of it I think it's in a hard
place because it's I think it was it's
like trying to be a competitor right
it's a competitor to what to all the
other options out there for everyone but
I I feel like all I hear is that
everyone's just like unhappy with it
please right well so let's see
Obamacare is does not provide health
insurance Obamacare mandated
that everybody needed to have for-profit
health insurance so it's coming from all
the same for-profit companies so or pay
a fine if you opted not to have health
care at all that was called the
individual mandate which the Trump
administration has done away with in
that sense Obamacare was interestingly
Obamacare was really conceived by the
Heritage Foundation a very conservative
organization in the 90s because it
mandates tens of millions of new
customers for for-profit insurance
companies so the opposite of socialism
the opposite of left-wing is their
incentive was purely monetary whose
incentive the Heritage Foundation well
they're the incentive of the of the
for-profit health insurance companies is
that the government will say everybody
has to go and get a for-profit insurance
plan from these for-profit insurance
right so their incentive was was just
monetary the right the insurance
companies were standing to get tens of
millions of new customers from that so
the complaints about Obamacare there's
there's different complaints about
Obamacare one is that the premiums of
the healthcare.gov plans increased from
one year to the next now the reason
that's not particularly interesting or
unique kritis criticism is that health
care premiums inside of obamacare
exchanges and outside of obamacare
exchanges have been rising for decades
in the United States like that's the
problem the problem is that it continues
to get more and more expensive every
year for mediocre coverage and people
ending up having to pay more and more
out-of-pocket so it's true that premiums
went up within the Obamacare exchanges
but they also went up outside of the
Obamacare exchanges even more quickly so
that's not a very good criticism the
criticisms about the financial viability
of Obamacare are not unfair but they are
significantly influenced by the fact
that you need that individual mandate in
order to make the system financially
viable and what Donald Trump came in and
did was he said well you don't have to
have you
have to pay that fine if you don't get
one of those programs that's how
actuarial calculations work which is you
have to have everybody needs to be in
the pool so to speak everybody needs to
be in the risk pool and if you're not
there needs to be some financial
compensation otherwise the numbers don't
work so that would be a criticism but
that would be one that we should really
be looking at Donald Trump for because
he's the one who ended that individual
mandate so it's again to say everybody's
basically unhappy with Obamacare
Republicans had two plans that were so
unpopular which would have gotten rid of
the Obamacare that supposedly everybody
is unhappy with and they were such
obvious political dead ends that with
the Republican president a Republican
house and a Republican Senate they
weren't able to get it done because they
didn't have enough Republican support
because Republicans realize this is way
worse than what we have right now and
tens of millions of people are going to
end up losing insurance so okay so what
how you go around and and you probably
have this conversation like all the time
with callers other people you talk to
and whatnot and so what does that like
for you because you're obviously very
knowledgeable on the topic and and a lot
of people agree and a lot of people
disagree I guess like what what do you
what's it what's it like for you to go
around and and oh you get used to it I
mean I think you're talking to people
who disagree with me about things all
the time I mean my approach with callers
is to get them to examine where they got
some of these ideas and to really
examine whether the foundations of those
ideas are strong or not and to hopefully
get them to reconsider if they're not so
I will very often ask how did you come
to that conclusion
what evidence if I could present it to
you would get you to change or change
your mind why do you think I've come to
the conclusion that I've come to and
those can all be good conversation
starters sort of to get people to
consider maybe I'm misinformed about
this maybe I don't actually understand
what
what I'm talking about that that's sort
of my approach I mean if people call
into my show for example and just want
to yell and scream and tell me I'm a bad
person
okay I mean it's sort of entertaining I
guess to some people and I'm probably
not going to change that person's mind
but the idea for me is let's let's
really think hard about how we came to
hold the beliefs that we hold and only
then can we really start to evaluate
whether these are good ideas bad ideas
and we can kind of go from there and
like we were mentioning earlier like
this is kind of a newer phenomenon being
talked about in America right now social
democracy because so what why do you
think it's like a current conversation
you mentioned the wealth gap you know
inequality growing how how did that
happen how did the conversation about
social democracy sort of rise well I
think that that's on the rise because
the conversation on wealth inequalities
is becoming more prominent as well and
sure I think people think that's a
solution so how did the how did the
problem of like say wealth inequality
and and you know other problems that
people think is happening right now how
do we get to that point I mean I know a
lot of people criticize probably
capitalism I don't know from free-market
system or I I don't know what do you
think well it's important to understand
that the u.s. does not have a total
free-market system
it's a capitalist system where some
markets are free and some are not and in
fact some of the biggest corporations
benefit from the fact that we don't have
a totally free market in a lot of areas
I mean health insurance is one where
it's very difficult to have markets that
span across state lines if you really
want to have a free market we should
have more across state lines selling
when you talk about you know cable
companies cable companies are not really
operating in a free market and there is
significant what's called regulatory
capture where industries control the
entities that are supposed to be
regulating them so the cable industry is
a great example where the people who are
deciding about how should cable and
internet service providers be regulated
are often attorneys from previously from
those companies the current head of the
FCC was a Verizon lawyer Ajit PI so
once you understand that we have free
markets sort of in the United States
where it's convenient for large
corporations that wield lots of
political power that kind of opens the
door a little bit to getting into
understanding how we got to where we are
today people call crony capitalism sure
that's part of it yeah I mean regulatory
capture is part of crony crony
capitalism disproportionately having
industry people and corporate lawyers in
elected official positions is part of
crony capitalism the sort of lobbyist
politician revolving door Industrial
Complex is another part of that but at a
very high level you know we got to where
we are today
because large corporations and very rich
people wield disproportionate control
over what is law
how is taxation done how is regulation
done how do all facets of society work
and when you have that for a period of
decades and decades in the United States
you're going to get that growth
inequality you're going to get wage
stagnation for most people and
significant wage increases for the
people at the very top I mean it's all
exactly as predicted the questions and
the debates for me or more what are the
approaches to solve these issues and
that's where there's there's more
disagreement there's actually less
disagreement about what the issues are
interestingly enough the disagreement is
about whether these are problems and
what approaches we should take to fix
them and so it's so funny because I
remember watching did you ever see that
video with Peter Schiff where he's
holding it was during the Occupy Wall
Street protests and he went down you
know Peter Schiff is this I think it's a
hedge fund yes but he's a big
businessman and he he went down with a
scientist and I'm a part of the 1% like
talked to me so it was this whole video
but so I think he I would assume he's on
the very free-market side but one of the
big arguments he was making was what you
were making which was like what you guys
should be fighting for is getting
businesses and government out of hoots
with each other sure and so I think
that's so interesting that you know I
like hearing you talk and hearing him
talk who I would think are probably
opposite views it's like you guys see
the same yeah I mean sometimes there are
overlaps between
different types of libertarian ideas so
like I'm on the Left libertarian rather
than left authoritarian if you think
about the political rather than a
political spectrum that goes left to
right you think about it sort of like as
a crosshairs with four quadrants so my
tendency is more libertarian and there's
definitely right libertarians who want
to separate business and government
sometimes the path to that also includes
doing away with all regulation on
businesses businesses all together which
I'm not for right so on that part we
would probably disagree I've not seen
the video you're talking about but it
wouldn't be surprising that on some of
these issues
I do have overlap with some more sort of
center-right libertarians on in a sort
of narrow way I want to be very clear
not not in any of these anti regulation
ways that probably go along with these
views it I heard and correct me if I'm
wrong I heard that a lot of these nordic
countries that do have high taxes and
like socialistic programs they actually
have fewer regulations than we do on
their businesses do you know if that's
true well when you say socialistic
programs I know I keep struggling with
how to put that I guess distribution
right like higher taxes so they can have
you know these free programs right well
the programs aren't free it's just
they're being paid for in a different
way that's a really important thing
through higher taxes you're paying
through taxation it's not always higher
it's just drastically different
priorities when you don't have the
defense spending that the United States
has without necessarily needing higher
tax rates you can pay for a lot of other
stuff that's what's really important to
sort of understand so it's not free but
it's paid for in a different way I think
that the sort of 30,000 foot view on
those countries is that you're
completely right that they don't have
particularly poor business environments
in business climates there's plenty of
really rich people in Sweden and in
Denmark a per capita of course there are
countries with smaller populations the
people are very happy there when you
look at every single year you look at
self-reported happiness studies the
people in those countries
whatever freedom a right-winger in the
US says they are lacking there does not
seem to be holding down
in those countries a life expectancy is
very high education is very good there's
no such thing as medical bankruptcy so
III think that it's again these are
capitalist countries that have said we
are going to be instead of this
capitalist we're going to be this
capitalist and this little piece at the
top we're going to use to make sure
nobody gets left behind and to put some
limits at the very top it's working out
quite well for them so it's so back to
the the regulation do you think do you
know know if they do have like less
regulation than we do
I heard that so it's a very regulations
a very broad term so it's important that
we distinguish between regulation in
terms of the relationship between the
employer and the employee regulation
when it comes to pollution we need to
really drill into what type of
regulation we're talking about if we
don't do that it's very difficult to say
there's more or less regulation are we
measuring by the number of regulations
are we measuring by how long it takes to
register a new business like that's a
metric that sometimes is used to allude
to how much bureaucracy is there we need
a little more detail yeah interesting I
guess I've just heard that that
generally they have less and that that
might be one of the reasons why they're
pro-business so I thought that could be
you know I don't know I guess I wonder
if that would be a trade off for those
who who are I don't know maybe very
free-market or against I guess the
opposite sides of you it's like well
could that be a trade off then like you
know lower regulation to help businesses
thrive while also offering these more
Universal programs I don't well I think
it's important to know that less
regulation to help businesses thrive
what it means is to socialize the
negative externalities of what
businesses do and that's not a good
thing so I think number one it's really
important to understand that when we say
less regulation let's businesses thrive
it's happening at the expense of
something so like as an example we could
say you know what it would be great for
businesses they would thrive if we
reduced environmental regulations on
them certainly I'm sure lots of
businesses would be able to make more
money if we eliminated eliminated
environmental regulations but the
environment is
to pay that cost which will then be
socialized across taxation in order to
clean up or fix the damage that's done
so for me it's less a question of just
do we want to just let businesses thrive
and do whatever they want its who do we
want to pay who do we want to have pay
for the damage that businesses can do in
many industries should it be the
businesses themselves that are making
the profit I think the answer is yes
should it be tax payers who are victims
of pollution and corruption and fraud
and crony capitalism I don't think that
that's who should pay I think we should
be the companies interesting and I think
that's that's such an economic answer
and I like that because I think you know
in me and my journey and learning about
economics you know you've learned it oh
it's not just about numbers it's not
just about money moving around it's
actually about allocation of resources
and it's sometimes like effort right and
and I kind of like that example like by
making this one decision how does this
affect something else sure and how does
that affect something else I mean a
business activity whether it's drilling
for oil or whether it's a shipping
business that has a carbon footprint or
whatever that activity is going to have
some total impact on the planet and the
debate really is over who should bear
the costs of that impact and that is a
really important aspect of social
democracy which is social democracy is
not saying the business shouldn't exist
it's not saying the owners of the
business shouldn't be able to make a lot
of money it is saying however that the
negative externalities that result from
that business should be borne by the
business itself not by the taxpayers and
everyday people interesting interesting
well unfortunately I have I have limited
time with you so is there is there any
way that you think is best to kind of
you know summarize this conversation
over social democracy and you know why
you think it's it's a great system to go
by sure well listen I think that when we
look at the history of humans
when humans really started to advance in
the direction of becoming modern was
when agriculture was first developed and
people started owning stuff however that
same ownership of stuff brought with it
problems that had to be solved it
brought with it disease because people
started to live together in higher
populations rather than being
hunter-gatherers that moved around it
brought the beginning of this inequality
as some people owned a lot more stuff
than other people so I believe that
social democracy is the path forward
because there are lots of good things
that have developed in history of Homo
sapiens as a result of the start of
ownership culture so to speak but we
need to make sure that we have a system
that understands that it brings with it
negative things as well it brings with
it in equality it brings with it issues
related to education and health and the
relationships between people and so many
other things and the role of government
should be to sort of find a place where
the positives of ownership society and
individualism and entrepreneurship can
exist but be tempered by the
understanding that we have more than
enough resources to make sure that
nobody gets left behind at the bottom
that nobody has to file bankruptcy
because they can't afford health care
that everybody can get a reasonable
education and that's the the place where
social democracy sits or exists okay is
there anything else that you feel like
we didn't cover that you think is
something else important to just throw
out there real quick no I don't think so
people can you know if they like what I
said there's many places they can find
the the work that I do if they didn't I
don't want to hear from I'm talking
about we disagree like no no I yeah I do
they should call into my program and
argue actually yeah right well where can
people find you david pakman.com is the
best place or just find the podcast on
any one of those platforms iTunes
stitcher Pandora Spotify all of those or
our youtube channel as well and it's
called david pakman show the david
pakman show easy well thank you so much
for coming on I wish we had more time
absolute to do this again thank you
thank you hey everyone thanks so much
for watching the episode
if you're interested in contributing to
the conversation and supporting the show
there's two easy things you can do one
click subscribe and to visit our patreon
page where you get exclusive access to
the exploring minds community